Ella when are you and Aiden gonna have
kids I love because I want kids
why don't you want kids well you want
kids the family is everything I have a
family don't worry your clock will kick
in I mean what do you do all day without
kids
[Music]
I've been through this a million times
and I'm happy with or without kids I
really wish I believed them it's a
couple of Empty Chairs at the table Dad
can we not
I don't want
I never have I actually don't have a
clock all women have a biological clock
maybe yours is just
broken
new biotech firm doing a clinical trial
this month I can get you in
it is the singular evolutionary goal of
a species to procreate that is our
purpose we administer a newly engineered
synthetic hormone pair that with
cognitive behavioral therapy and the
option of an implant
deep breath
I might be a tough case you're not a
case to me Ella you're a human being and
the best kind too what kind is that
a woman
you want kids today we'll be learning to
perform maintenance the family is
everything on a working clock
to reset the Cog I am out of time
[Music]
out of time working clock
shut up
oh yeah
[Music]